right riley reef of the minnesota
vikings who has been with the team for
three years he signed a five-year deal
after his rookie contract with the lions
ended he was the first round pick in
2012.
he's got that c on his jersey yeah they
don't have a jersey any longer this
one's amazing to me
although in hindsight i guess i'm not
really all that surprised
the vikings are playing the take a pay
cut or take a hike
game with riley reef in the out years of
his contract there's no guaranteed money
left there was no trigger back in march
to have a big roster bonus or guarantee
his salary so
this happens all the time and look is it
right well
i don't know they have the right to do
it you go to a veteran player with an
inflated
salary and you say when there's not
any real time to find another job we
don't want to pay you 10.9 million this
year we're going to pay you x instead
take it or leave it and if you leave it
we leave you behind yeah and riley reef
i'm told was telling teammates yesterday
he expects to be cut now maybe this is
part of the stare down
right maybe this is part of the poker
space that he needs to show
right as the vikings decide whether or
not they want to go forward without
riley reef
but you know chris i we see this every
year it happens every year
some guys take pay cuts some guys don't
but it's always hard to go out there and
get what you would have gotten
or get what they would have paid you on
a reduced contract signing with a new
team
less than two weeks before the start of
yeah well you know as a player you're
you're handicapped here i mean what are
you what are you supposed to do
yeah you're not going to go on the free
market right now or or get cut and find
that contract out there
you'll have a hard time you know there's
only going to be a limited amount of
teams that might even want your services
at this point
you know yeah i mean he'll have some
action but you know for the most part
teams have got their guys in there and
they've been taking reps and they've got
the
you know the the the unity as far as
between the five starting offensive
linemen
like to me this is like and especially
in a year like this it's even worse
with the pandemic and everything like
this it's
kind of uh you know to me bad business i
wish this is something that they'd find
a way to get rid of the nfl or
or you know nfl players oh
oh i'm the starting tailback oh oh i'm
i'm not going to play week one now then
i'm the starter until i get a new
contract oh
oh i'm starting at right tackle this
week oh you cut the other guys that were
competing
oh i mean then this is what players need
to do they need to start doing the same
games this is what
i would argue uh because this is one of
the tougher things as a player you're
really in a tough spot here
you can't get away with that though you
can't you cannot do it i mean i advocate
yeah i know it's players yes but the
idea of threatening to walk out or not
play
to abandon your team at the start of the
series i've made the argument before
that a guy should hold out of the
playoffs right i made that argument on
le'veon bell's behalf
that that's the time to do it that's
your maximum leverage
that if you're one of these first round
picks that played really well and you
finished your third season
and you're getting ready to go to the
postseason like patrick mahomes
hey pay me my contract now or i'm i'm
i'm not playing in the playoffs
you're gonna alienate the fans you're
gonna alienate your teammates
you're just gonna you are doesn't like
football
and and you're going to be you're going
to be strapped with that for the rest of
your career
so i the the answer is simple chris
the contracts have to be negotiated so
that in every year
there is that requirement to make a
decision
early yeah two million dollar roster
bonus payable on march 15. that's the
fix
five million dollars of the salary
becomes fully guaranteed on march 15
whatever it is
you force them to deal with you with
your salary
and with your cap number in march so
they can't play this game
because the way it's set up they can and
here's what happens
and this this technically it's tampering
the agent will call around
once the agent knows what the vikings
are willing to pay riley reeve he'll
call around to other teams saying
what would you pay rally reef what would
you pay rally reef it's tampering
for the teams to engage in those
conversations but it happens and you
need to know
as the agent you need to know what's
behind door number two before you tell
the vikings to stick door number one up
their butts so
pardon me sorry london but uh but that
that's
that's how this works and you don't want
to be in that spot
where you're all of a sudden on a monday
afternoon
in late august calling every team in the
league saying do you need a new life
tackle
right two weeks from the start of the
season yeah no i mean you're exactly
right
you know and just to hit on like the
football aspect of this in minnesota
there's obviously got to be somebody in
camp that's impressing them to know that
okay well if riley
does walk away you know rashad hill
who's a guy who's played tackle for them
before in minnesota you know he maybe
he's impressing so they're not afraid if
riley reef does walk away i will say i'm
a little surprised i am
you know again this was one a pretty
damn good offensive line last year as
far as the run game's concerned
pass protection wise not the best always
but
uh you know this is this is the tough
thing about no preseason it's moves like
this
offensive line we can't evaluate him we
can't see him we don't know oh this guy
got put in with the first team offensive
line he must be impressing and those are
context clues we usually get and we're
just
totally clueless right now as far as
that stuff is concerned
my understanding is that the thought
would be brian o'neill moves from right
tackle left tackle
rod hill steps up as the right tackle
ezra cleveland was drafted in round two
by the vikings to eventually replace
riley reef
he's not ready for that yet in fact they
were trying to mount a guard but
apparently that didn't not enough but
there not enough uh
not enough not enough power there to
handle that yet i don't think
and and so they go forward if this
happens if this isn't some big bluff by
the vikings and i don't think they tend
to bluff i think they go to riley reef
serious that this is what they're
willing to pay and if he says no then
they move on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports